how's it going everybody there have been
a lot of supposed plot leaks for
Avengers sport there's no real way of
knowing what's real and what's not but
one thing they all have in common is
time travel and with some new
information that was apparently leaked
today there is more evidence to support
one plot leak my giveaway continues if
you'd like a chance to win a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray or
ant-man and the loss of some special
edition posters and memorabilia all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so one of the Avengers for
plot league says that Avengers 4
actually starts years into the future
afterthe an osa snap there's a lot of
ways that this can make sense but it
appears that we've gotten more specific
information about this today according
to Daniel RPK who is a writer for Super
bro movies Avengers 4 it will take place
five years after the events of Avengers
infinity war this would give us a chance
to see how the remaining Avengers and
society reacts to the events of the snap
in the years to come this also supports
some leaks set photos we've seen where
we see Tony Stark who apparently is
older and has blond hair this makes
sense of these photos because Tony Stark
is clearly older in these photos and if
it's five years into the future he is
indeed older so what do you all think
about this supposedly does it make sense
I think there's a good argument for why
the Russo brothers would want to start
Avengers 4 5 years after the events of
infinity work but what do you all think
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything happening with Avengers 4
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]
you
[Music]